this is my impression of a guy who
thinks that numbers should be arranged
alphabetically
eight five
four
nine one seven six ten three two zero
thank you and now this is my impression
of a guy who is counting but the only
numbers he knows are numbers whose names
in English are spelled with all of their
letters in alphabetical order
how many do I have let me find out 40
thank you and now this is my impression
of a guy who is counting but the only
numbers he knows are numbers whose names
in English are spelled with their
letters in Reverse alphabetical order
one
[Music]
thank you in the English language if you
look at all the number names that we
have that are found in dictionaries the
very first alphabetically would be
billion the first Roman numeral
alphabetically is 100 and the last is 38
unless you write 9 like this in which
case it's 39.